this is Atlas the brawler the strong
master of earth and stone he alters the
environment with an incredible force
atlases abilities are honed for both
closed and ranged combat while also
passively immune to knockdown effects as
long as he touches the ground landslides
propels Atlas forward punching enemies
in his path recasting within a time
window will provide a combo bonus
increasing damage and reducing energy
costs with each successful chain
tectonics creates a rock barrier in
front of Atlas that blocks enemies if
deactivated while the barrier is active
it will turn into a deadly Boulder that
rolls toward your aim point eventually
exploding with radial damage petrify
slowly turns enemies in atlases view to
stone the closer in proximity at enemy
gets the quicker they slow down take the
weight off your shoulders teto Rumblers
summons to rock men to battle alongside
Atlas while primarily melee attackers
they can also throw rocks at distant
targets if disabled while rock men are
still active they will explode causing
damage to enemies nearby the addition of
mods to atlases loadout will help him
grow into a stronger tighten all of
Atlas abilities are benefited by range
and strength mods including duration
mods will positively affect all of his
abilities except tectonics moving
mountains is no
- adverse in juice